Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome to this brand new series on pediatric dentistry.
Now pediatric dentistry is multidisciplinary in nature and it encompasses a wide range
of the other specialties.
So these videos, if you're watching them after some of my other series, may provide
some helpful overlap and review with some of the other sections.
Now with that in mind, pediatric dentistry is certainly not the same as adult dentistry
because kids and primary teeth present some unique challenges and we need to talk about
what those are.
So we're going to cover a lot of great topics in this series and it's definitely one of
the most requested as of recently.
The board examiners combine orthodontics and pediatric dentistry into one category and
their guidelines but I think it's honestly more helpful to focus on each one of those
individually so that's why I'm going to have a separate series for each of them.
So that being said, like all my videos, I'm going to focus only on the highest yield things
that you need to know for the board exam.
My hope is that these videos will help you prepare for it and also give you a nice overview
for clinical application and general knowledge.
So with that, let's get started and talk about odontogenesis or tooth development.
And this is honestly a very complex topic but I'm excited to boil it down in the most
simplified way possible for you.
Now tooth development is dependent on both genetic control and also environmental factors
like nutrition, trauma, infection, or even excess fluoride intake during tooth formation
and we'll talk more about these environmental factors and developmental disturbances and
anomalies in the following video.
So this is a really nice schematic showing the different developing layers and the different
stages from beginning to erupted tooth.
Now we're going to talk about all of these in detail and I'm definitely going to focus
on the bud, the cap, and the bell stages which are nice to remember because each of those
is corresponding to the shape that the enamel organ is assuming in each one of those stages.
So let's talk about each one in detail starting with thickening or initiation.
So initiation starts six weeks in utero and this is referring to how long the fetus has
been developing in the womb.
So there are a couple of layers that we have to address here.
The oral epithelium is the outer layer of the developing mouth and this has both an upper
and a lower arch form that referring to the upper and the lower part of the eventual and
ultimate mouth.
The dental lamina is a thickening of this oral epithelium and the first evidence of
a forming or budding tooth.
Now this image is a two-dimensional cross section so imagine that the thickened area
is going both into the screen and coming out of the screen to create a whole row of thickened
oral epithelium where individual teeth will eventually pinch off from.
The ectomecin chime is this thick underlying purple layer and that signals the overlying
oral epithelium to proliferate into the dental lamina.
Now the oral epithelium and the dental lamina are both derived from the ectoderm.
The ectomecin chime is also derived from the ectoderm but more specifically the neural crest.
It's called the ectomecin chime because it's derived from the ectoderm indirectly but it
develops into tissue that is physiologically similar to mesenchymal tissue or mesoderm
derived tissue.
Failure in this very first step can lead to major issues either the tooth is completely
missing or we get an extra tooth.
The next stage is the bud stage and this begins eight weeks in utero so two weeks later.
Here the dental lamina is quickly growing and invades into the underlying mesenchym.
So these proliferating areas of the dental lamina are pinching off to produce these buds
and these buds are called dental placodes.
Now this is really important.
All primary teeth and permanent molars arise directly from this dental lamina.
So they look exactly as the schematic is showing here but permanent incisors, canines and premolars
arise from their primary predecessor.
So what does that mean?
Well a secondary bud pinches off from the first bud so imagine there's a separate smaller
bud coming off right around there and that goes through the same stages from this point
forward to develop the permanent teeth except for the molars.
Now in this make sense because these are all succedaneous teeth or teeth that eventually
replace a primary tooth whereas all of the primary teeth and the permanent molars have
no teeth that they're replacing.
They're the first ones in their respective regions to come into the mouth.
So I find that that's the best way to remember this concept and to keep that information straight.
Now additionally the mesenchym is also beginning to condense underneath the bud and that's
what these dark blue, dark purple dots are showing that this tissue is starting to condense
directly underneath that bud.
Here in the bud stage again results in congenitally missing teeth where the budding process doesn't
occur at all or supernumerate teeth where we have excessive budding happening.
Alright next we have the cap stage and this happens 9 weeks in utero.
So the cap stage is also known as proliferation and it's when the bud continues to grow and
proliferate while also differentiating into some new layers.
Now each dental plaque code shown here grows and indents to form the enamel organ.
So this is now called the enamel organ.
And the enamel organ will ultimately create the enamel.
Now we're not anywhere close to that stage yet but just keep that in the back of your
head.
The enamel organ consists of various very important layers to remember.
The first is the OEE or outer enamel epithelium.
And this is the outer cell layer so it's what I'm highlighting right here.
I'll try to get these in a couple different colors for you.
The next layer is the inner enamel epithelium and that is the inner cell layer so that's
going to be this part right there.
And next we have the stelate reticulum which are the cells between the OEE and the IEE.
So that's all of this stuff all in here.
And finally we have the enamel knot which are these little areas of focal thickening.
I kind of covered it up but there are these points or peaks along this inner enamel epithelium
that eventually determine where the cusp tips will be.
And they're also the signaling centers for the developing tooth.
Now that condensed mesenchyme that we were talking about before aggregates and now it
finally forms its own entity and it's called the dental papilla.
So essentially the dental papilla is now wearing this enamel organ as a sort of cap.
The dental papilla will ultimately create and become the dentin and the pulp.
Again as with the other things in italicized font here that's just an ultimate goal but
we're not anywhere close to that point yet in the tooth development process.
So the dental follicle is the sac that surrounds the enamel organ and the dental papilla.
So you can think of it like this black outline that encircles this entire enamel organ and
underlying dental papilla.
So again the dental papilla is wearing the enamel organ as its cap and the dental follicle
surrounds it all.
Failure in this process could result in congenitally missing or supernumerate teeth if it occurs
early on but more likely you're going to see a cyst, odontoma, germination or fusion or
dentindente depending on the amount of cell differentiation that has occurred.
Alright next we have the bell stage and this one begins 11 weeks in utero and there are
two components or two phases in the bell stage.
The first is called histodifferentiation, histo meaning tissue and this is where we get
differentiation and transformation of those layers we were talking about into distinct
cell types that will be responsible for secreting our final tooth tissue hence the name here.
So the cells of the inner enamel epithelium differentiate into ameloblasts whereas the
cells of the dental papilla differentiate into odontoblasts all of which are tall and
columnar in shape.
Now I matched the colors here it might be a little bit hard to see I apologize they're
very thin but that darker tan layer is the ameloblasts which were part of the IEE and
then this part that kind of burgundy color thin layer are the odontoblasts that outer
portion of the dental papilla right up against that IEE.
So that junction right there is going to be the eventual dentin enamel junction, the
DEJ of that tooth.
Now this makes sense because ameloblasts are secreting enamel and the odontoblasts are
going to be secreting dentin which is consistent with what we saw in the previous slide.
Now defects in this process of histodifferentiation can cause amelogenesis imperfecta where you
get abnormal enamel formation you get this yellow brown discoloration or dentinogenesis
imperfecta where you get abnormal dentin formation or this brown greatest coloration and again
this all makes sense because of what is happening during this stage.
So hopefully you can draw those connections and really help to lock this into your brain.
The second phase is called morpho differentiation, morpho meaning form, structure, shape.
This is where we determine the size and the shape of the eventual tooth crown.
Now of course this is also happening simultaneously with histodifferentiation hence why I have the
same time period of 11 weeks in utero for the bell stage.
So it makes sense that a failure in a stage that's all about determining shape and size
are going to have shape and size abnormalities like peg laterals, macrodontia, and a couple
more that we'll talk about in our next video.
So next we have apposition.
Now an apposition happening 14 weeks in utero, first we're going to have those odontoblasts
secreting a dentin matrix of collagen which then signals the amule blasts to secrete an
enamel matrix of amuleogenin.
Then after the enamel starts being produced the cervical loop jumps into the action and
root development starts to take place.
Now the cervical loop is where the IEE and the OEE layers meet.
So that's going to be right at this point here where that outer enamel epithelium and
that inner enamel epithelium now amule blasts joins together and here's the point on this
side here.
So our cervical loop going circumferentially around the developing tooth bell.
So this part, the cervical loop elongates and grows down.
So it's growing down in this direction.
And it forms an extension called hertz epithelial root sheath.
We'll just call it hertz for short.
And this stimulates odontoblasts to secrete radicular dentin which is dentin as part of
the root.
Now hertz eventually disintegrates leaving behind little clusters of cells called the
epithelial rests of ballastae that stay present in the ultimate periodontal ligament.
It's just a vestigial structure as part of the developing tooth.
Now the stellate reticulum that's this part here between the IEE and the OEE collapses
and deflates kind of like a popped balloon and the outer and inner enamel epithelium meet
together and lay along the top of the enamel matrix that's beginning to form.
And the combination of the deflated IEE and OEE becomes the reduced enamel epithelium.
And that kind of protects the tooth as it erupts and eventually it'll form the junctional
epithelium part of the gingiva.
And then what remains of the dental papilla will eventually become the pulp.
Now disturbances in this step where we're getting a position or initial laying down of
these matrices, you could get like trauma in the stage.
If you get trauma to a primary tooth, you could disrupt the cells while they're laying
down these initial matrix layers.
So say you have the primary teeth are erupted in the mouth and those permanent teeth are
currently going through a position at those secondary buds.
And if you knock a primary tooth, you can actually disrupt those ameloblasts, let's say, cause
some ameloblasts injury.
And this can result in localized areas of enamel hypoplasia called Turner's hypoplasia.
And again, we'll talk about that more in the next video if you're curious about that.
Alright, and we're almost done here, maturation is also known as calcification or mineralization.
And this one takes place at various time points for different teeth.
But important to know, this is by far the longest stage of tooth development and it involves
finally the deposition of the ultimate enamel and dentin.
We're in opposition, we're just kind of laying down those initial matrices, and now we're
talking about transforming those into the final tooth structure.
So the calcification process begins at the cusp tips and incisal edges where those enamel
knots were and proceeds in a cervical direction.
Now it takes two years for a primary tooth crown on average and four to five years on
average for a permanent tooth crown to complete this maturation process.
And that's not even including the root, it takes quite a few more years for the root
to finish developing.
So this is a really, really long process.
And now that explains why these disturbances, these defects rather, are so common because
the critical time period is much longer here.
There's a lot more time for something to go wrong.
So disturbances like localized infection and trauma can result in hypocalcification or
hypomineralization, those are those white spots.
You can get fluoresis if you have excessive systemic fluoride ingestion.
And fluoride ingestion greater than one PBM can affect ameloblasts.
So it causes a defective enamel matrix and a modelled enamel appearance.
Now this is going to be affecting children from their second trimester, a week 14 in
utero, through eight years old.
And that's the period while the teeth are forming 16 years if you count the wisdom teeth.
Now adults are not affected.
Tetracycline staining is kind of similar.
Tetracycline taken as an antibiotic can also cause intrinsic staining.
And it's also going to affect those same children from second trimester or week 14 through
eight years old while the teeth are forming.
But what's different here is that tetracycline doesn't mess up the enamel.
It binds to calcium and gets incorporated into the hydroxyapatite crystals in the dentin
layer.
So fluoresis messes up enamel, tetracycline stains the dentin.
And something very important to think about all this stuff with the defects is that the
later the disturbance occurs along this development process, the more minor the defect is, right?
We were talking about before with thickening and the bud stage if something went wrong,
we might just not have a tooth at all or we might end up with an extra tooth or teeth.
But if it happens a little bit later, well, we might get lucky and just have a little
white spot on there.
So it depends on when it occurs, how major that ultimate effect will be.
So a summary, we have our tooth germ, which includes the enamel organ, dental papilla,
dental follicle, follicle, and here are all the cells and cell layers and the materials
that are eventually produced by the cells of these certain layers.
So that will be an awesome reference for you.
And I really hope this has helped you kind of understand the complex, but also really
cool atontogenesis process.
Now for some other important dates to know, these are approximate calcification dates
for the primary teeth.
And I've arranged them ideally for the best and easiest memorization for you.
And also to know here, the calcification of primary tooth roots is normally completed
at around three to four years of age.
This is talking about the crowns and when they're starting to calcify.
Now here's a handy memorization tool that'll really help you remember this info.
The central incisors kind of using ortho-language here, they're the As we call them, the lateral
incisors are the Bs, canines are the Cs, first the primary first molars are the Ds and second
molars are the Es.
Now with that context, if you remember A, D, B, C, E, all you have to remember is you
start with 14, that's our lucky number of 14 weeks of age in utero, and you just add
one number down the rows here.
So if you remember A, D, B, C, E, you just have to remember 14 and add one down the row.
And that corresponds to the calcification start dates for these primary teeth.
So super cool, hope you can remember that and it can help you remember these calcification
dates.
Now I have another handy memorization tool that'll help you with the permanent teeth
as well.
In here I'm also using ortho-language one, the one referring to the central incisors and
then two, three, four, five, six, seven going down the row.
So here is a little bit more on the approximate side, but this is all you'll need to know for
the board exam.
So if you can keep this straight, it'll definitely be hopefully next to you a couple of questions.
So for this, remember, six, one, L2, that's lower two or lower lateral incisors, three,
up or two, four, five, seven.
So if you can remember this, then all you need to know is you start with zero and then
you add six for every row.
So you go zero, six, 12, 18, 24, 30, and this represents this information in the table.
So between this and this, you have a lot of great information if they asked you anything
about calcification dates, you have right there everything that you need to know.
So hopefully that's a blessing for you and you can use that to help make studying a little
bit easier.
Now after the tooth is developed and calcified, what happens next?
Well it needs to erupt into the mouth and this is the last thing we'll talk about in
the video.
Now I have a separate video covering this, but I really love this memory tool and I can't
help but share it with you guys here too.
I got this from another guy on YouTube and I think it's a brilliant way to remember eruption
sequence for the primary teeth, this in the lowercase nxi, and the permanent teeth, this
uppercase main.
So these two words or whatever you want to call them are really great to help you remember
eruption dates and sequence.
So first let's talk about the primary teeth.
Now all the eruption times I use are straight from the ADA website.
So these numbers here are in months.
And there is some discrepancy here but this is what I really urge you to remember for
the board exams because every tooth erupts within a range.
Normally it's within a six month time period, but for the board exam it's much more practical
I think to remember a single number for each tooth rather than a range that they could possibly
erupt in.
Even more important than the number is the order that these teeth normally erupt in.
So how we remember this is the word or phrase nxi all in lowercase.
And by drawing those three letters one straight to the next you get the sequence of eruption
of the primary teeth.
And before I start I'll just explain these are the centrals, the laterals, the canines,
the first primary molars and the second primary molars.
Alright, so if we start right here with this lower central incisor we draw our lowercase
n, we draw our x like this and then we skip over here and we finish with our i at the
end.
So after doing that you'll see that we went straight in order here from six months to
twenty six months and if you need additional help remembering the numbers you can remember
we have six, sixteen and twenty six all ending in six giving you reference points for this
entire sequence, so I think that's really really cool to be able to draw that out quickly
and to write those letters and to have all that information at your disposal in just
a few seconds.
And next we'll talk about the permanent teeth.
So all the eruption times here are again straight from the ADA website but this time they're
all in years.
Now these teeth also tend to erupt within a six month window but again I would learn
a single number for the board exam and focus most importantly on the sequence of eruption.
So how we remember this one is the word main all in uppercase and by drawing those four
letters separately starting with the i this will get you the sequence of eruption.
So we start and I will show you guys what all these mean this is the central and our
permanent teeth, central incisors, lateral incisors, canines, first premolars, second
premolars, first molars, second molars and we even have the third molars in there.
So we start with our i and we start with the lower first molar and we draw the i like this,
we jump back over to the central incisor the lower central incisor and we draw our m up
down up down.
Alright now we jump over here and our a is a little bit weird, we go up over down and
we have to finish our a so we go up like this and then we jump over to the lower second
molar and we only have one place to put our n and it's just like that.
So by starting in those areas, we get our sequence of eruption and I think it's just
so cool that there's a word that goes with it, it's uppercase which has to do with the
permanent teeth, it just works out so well and I'm just really impressed with this method
and I think it's just super super helpful to know for the board exam.
Now some other general facts that I have listed here that are really great for eruption, usually
mandibular teeth erupt before maxillary teeth, generally teeth in females erupt earlier than
those same teeth in males and in both males and females, tooth eruptions should occur symmetrically
in both jaws.
So if you have a lower left first premolar that's erupting, that lower right first premolar
should also be erupting or within a couple months of erupting.
If it's not then we then we're suspecting maybe the tooth is missing or it's impacted
or something's going on.
And finally something that I call the 2-3 rule and teeth normally erupt with 2/3 of their
roots having been developed, then after that point the root takes about 2-3 more years
after initial eruption to complete its root development.
So the 2-3 rule works for both aspects of the root.
The tooth will erupt when 2/3 of the root is developed and the root takes about 2-3 more
years after initial eruption to complete developing.
Alright so that's it for this video, thank you so much for watching guys, I really hope
you enjoyed learning about tooth development, calcification and eruption sequences.
A lot of high yield stuff in this video and I hope it helped.
If you're interested in supporting my channel, please check out my Patreon page, a huge thank
you to Michael Raja, Rabbi Boyd, Leonela Bungar, David Jaden, Yannet, Nicole, Isabella
Caldis, Ali Benjdier, Jacob K and all of my other patrons for their support.
You can unlock extras like access to these video slides if you want to take notes on
them and practice questions for the board exam, so go check that out, the link is in
the description below.
Please like this video if you enjoyed it, subscribe to the channel if you haven't already
and share it with your friends so more people can learn from mental dental.
Thanks again for watching everyone and I'll see you in the next video.